bonjour une solution à la pénurie
d'infirmières à mayotte ne centre
hospitalier de mamoudzou compte sur le
nouveau personnel en cours de formation
dans une école créée sur place
l'hôpital doit répondre aux besoins en
soins d'une population de 140 mille
habitants exposés au choléra ou au
paludisme n'a d'yeux amati aime son
métier infirmière aux urgences pourtant
comme ses quelques 200 concerts du
centre hospitalier de mayotte
elle exerce dans des conditions très
difficiles
yann 40 une grande part à ce défilé
mayotte ne fait pas l'exception
donc c'est un métier après président des
ja seulement voilà pour bien soigner les
patients il faut un personnel suffisant
et l'hôpital de mamoudzou manque
d'infirmières
le recrutement est difficile et 10% des
postes ne sont pas pourvus
heureusement l'année dernière le centre
hospitalier de mamoudzou a trouvé le
remède désormais des infirmières et des
infirmiers sont formés à mayotte dans le
cadre de l'institut de formation aux
soins infirmiers
ça va donner la possibilité de former
tous les ans les promotions de 15
étudiants donc infirmé l on entre à
l'institut de formation aux soins
infirmiers sur concours avec un niveau
baccalauréat ou 3 années d'expérience
validé dans le domaine sanitaire et
sociale la formation théorique et
pratique dure trois ans au bout un
diplôme d'état et la certitude de
trouver un emploi